das papier schoss
sag mal das haben wir auch schon seit
jahren nicht mehr das muss ich sagen ihr
habt die ihr habt die
holztür aus ab diesem holz hey leute was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen bio ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut ich weiß nicht ob ihr alle die
videos aus dem günstigsten und europas
bulgarien und dem teuersten land europas
der schweiz abgecheckt falls nicht kann
ich euch das noch ans herz legen ich
habe die chance auch genutzt um einmal
den günstigsten mcdonald's mit dem
teuersten mcdonald's zu vergleichen ich
weiß nicht wo auf der welt mcdonald's
noch günstiger ist aber man muss ja
sagen mcdonald's ist auf der welt
überall unterschiedlich so gibt es zb
einen cheeseburger in taiwan es gibt
tatsächlich parmesankäse und spaghetti
mit pesto im italienischen mcdonald's es
gibt ein greet mac in griechenland
mickey flut in thailand oder sogar die
mcdonald's pizza in verschiedenen
ländern das hatten wir glaube ich auch
schon mal in deutschen oder gab es hier
nicht irgendwann mal mcdonald's meine
pizza auf jeden fall gab es auch mal hot
dogs abgesetzt nach bulgarien und dann
in die schweiz allerdings wollte ich
euch bevor wir starten noch den big mac
index zeigen genauso wie mein
geographielehrer damals in der zehnten
klasse haben wir das nämlich auch
durchgenommen durchgenommen der big mac
index wird jedes jahr neu angepasst und
gibt an wie viel ein big mac überall auf
der welt in den verschiedenen ländern in
us dollar kostet die haben wir zum
beispiel das modell vom ersten quartal
2022 und die schweiz ist natürlich am
teuersten mit sechs dollar 890 und dann
haben wir tatsächlich russland mit nur
einem dollar 74 einfach und ist in das
da so günstig und man muss auch sagen in
russland war ich nicht ich war in
bulgarien aber bulgarien ist hier
irgendwie gar nicht aufgepasst da
bulgarien aber günstiger als rumänien
ist würde ich das mal irgendwo hier im
bereich zwischen russland und rumänien
einstufen und was ist eigentlich total
alter ist das land jetzt habe ich noch
nie gehört leute ich bin hier vom
bulgarischen mcdonald's und da gehen wir
jetzt mal rein
[Musik]
so leute ab in bulgarien mcdonald's was
man hier eine maske der bulgarische
mcdonald's war übrigens der einzige ort
in ganz bulgarien wo die mitarbeiter
eine maske getragen haben
ach leute bevor ich es vergesse die
gäste ihr seht mich so andauernd aus
dieser perspektive aber immer mit
verschiedenen outfits eigentlich waren
die produkte die ich da in bulgarien
bestellen konnte genauso wie in
deutschland es gab halt nur warte ich
weiß nicht was das hier war das war
irgendwie was anderes aber ich hab mich
gestellt und ich weiß auch nicht ganz
genau ob es diese bürger in deutschland
gibt ja für spät
[Musik]
laut and wonder florida für smarties
smarties jedes mal wenn ich in
deutschland zu mcdonald's gehen dann
bestätigt mir hin und wieder mal max
frie mit smarties aber die kanten dort
nicht mal smarties also die marke
smarties war dem kassierer kein begriff
aber ich habe es ihm dann erklärt tesch
ich bin immer ein leute cheeseburgern
bulgarien 1 euro 10 wie damals in
deutschland super entspannt 1 euro 10
geil und ein einzelner big mac
umgerechnet zwei euro fünfzig
leute ich habe mir hier ist ein big mac
mini geholt und jetzt schon ewig keinen
sieg mit ne ne pommes
und cola für 15 lieber selbst bin ich
auch mal sehr gespannt wie teuer diese
kombination in der schweiz ist kein
platz also sich saurer soße und ketchup
kosten einfach 50 cent so gesehen dass
ist schon finde ich ein bisschen feuer
dann im vergleich zu dem essen also man
muss sagen bulgarische mcdonald's auf
jeden fall schon sehr günstig aber wenn
man ketchup mai oder süß saurer soße
extra bestellt das ist dann schon echt
geil ist mäßig teuer
ja es hat eigentlich ist es ja auch
normal dass man ein backshop mit dabei
hat aber die bulgaren essen
wahrscheinlich gerne lieber pommes ohne
legen wir das ist jetzt hier die obere
etage von den dingen ducati toilette
aber hier ist ja niemand kann so ist das
also wenn ein mcdonalds komplett leer
ist alles in allem aber eigentlich
geschmeckt wie in deutschland fast ein
wunder umgerechnet für ein großes big
mac mini und mac pro die habe ich
bezahlt knapp 7 euro 50 ich hätte
gedacht das ist noch günstiger aber man
kann auf keinen fall meckern und dann
ging es weiter in die schweiz genauer
gesagt nach zürich die teuerste stadt ja
ist es die teuerste stadt der welt auf
jeden fall ist dort der big mac am
teuersten in der schweiz ja sowieso aber
mir wurde gesagt zürich ist noch mal
einen ticken teurer also der mac ist in
zürich das heißt auch schwierig ob zu
mcdonald's
das war schon
bekannt
ich habe heute nacht hier beim logos
übernachtet und dem habe ich gesagt wir
müssen noch einmal zu mcdonald's heute
nacht wir waren hier in unserem klub
weil die jobs auch in deutschland ist ja
alles zu und danach sind wir noch
zusammen in dessen gegangen und in
diesem bis habe ich eine margarita pizza
bestellt und eistee zusammen sind zehn
euro also 17 schweizer franken kann man
kommt ja ungefähr hin das muss man sich
mal vorstellen
mein lieber was meinst aber nicht mehr
jetzt hier zum beispiel so einen big mac
mini bestell und marc lory wohl antwort
preislich ganz schön und ich weiß es
nicht und überhaupt ich kenne die preise
nicht mehr wächst also dein cousin meint
im 18
das sieht aber wirklich schon super
schön aus eurem mcdonald's hier also da
bezahle ich auch wirklich gerne 18 euro
für muss ich sagen hey leute gebt euch
das mal weiß ob man sehen kann 13
schweizer franken kosten wie das hier
schon losgeht 13 schweizer franken für
einen bigmac menü also fast doppelt so
teuer wie in bulgarien alles zusammen
mit eis komme ich leute
wirklich jetzt ist das jetzt auf
spezifische nein das ist alles deutsch
oder englisch
und in der schweiz einschießt begleitet
euch fest zwei franken 90 also fast drei
euro für einen cheeseburger
jetzt bin ich gespannt nimmt martina das
mit dem odenwald ihnen das ist so geil
also ich muss auch hier sagen ich jetzt
mal gedacht das ist teuer wird aber 18
schweizer franken ist ja geisteskrank
also das sind umgerechnet irgendwas
zwischen 17 und 18 europa was wir waren
so
den hang masters
in der schweiz gibt es übrigens hier
diese home style hanni mustard burger
und so die gibt es in deutschland gar
nicht voll schade weil die waren so geil
ehrlich aber sonst war von mir
eigentlich auch alles gleich
leute es uns angekommen wieso habt ihr
noch plastik ströme wenn man fragen darf
ich keine papierspur
sag mal das haben wir auch schon seit
jahren nicht mehr
aus diesem holz
wirklich das ist ganz klar
deine handschrift vier dieser art ist
das ein bisschen
was einfach nur das menü 18 franken also
17 euro gefördert ihr habt taxiert
und
ich muss sagen nach meinen reisen und ja
der erfahrung dass die kaufkraft in
diesen unterschiedlichen ländern
wirklich schon extrem variiert also du
kannst in bulgarien mit einem geld echt
viel machen während du in der schweiz ja
eigentlich gar nichts machen kannst das
ist auf jeden fall schon echt heftig und
ich hatte nicht gedacht dass es so
extrem ist ihr könnt ihr eure meinung
dazu in die kommentare schreiben auch
hätte ich gedacht dass der big mac
irgendwie in indonesien oder vielleicht
irgendwo in afrika am günstigsten ist
aber das ist ja nicht so ich hoffe dass
wieder hat euch gefallen heute last sehr
genau nach oben da wir sehen uns
abonnieren nicht vergessen haut rein tja
und ihr könnt auch sehr gerne meinen
zweikanal abschrecken weil da kommen
aktuell jeden tag neue videos